صار انه همم
الحركه الشيرازيه اقرب للاخوان المسلمين
العمليه الحركيه والاجتماعيه ال- اا
خط الامام اللي تفرع منها بعدين حزب الله
الحجاز في قضيه الروحانيه والعرفان همم
الثقه للعلمي للخميني في النجف ولو ولو ان
ما كان مرجع تقليد همم واسع النطاق بس بعض
ابناء الاسر العلميه المشهوره بالاحساء
درسوا عنده وتاثروا باسلوبها الروحاني
اكثر من اسلوب الفقه اكثر اسلوب الفقهي
فانتشر بشكل كبير
في المصطلح السني شيخ الطريقه الصوفيه
يعني او مربي الصوفي اكثر من كونه فقيه
متضلع يعني ربما هذه من نقاط الجاذبيه
التي جربت بعض الناس همم له في منطقه
الاحساء بشكل خاص وفي نقطه اذا الوحده
طبعا
روحانيه حتى بتلاقي شيء غير مسيسيين همم
متاثرين جدا بل حتى الامور السياسيه
وهمم مخلب النسر اللي كارتر حاول يحار
فيها الرهائن في صحراء طبس همم
وتحطم الطائرات ارجعها الى هي همم فالنقطه
هذه همم حملت مريدين كثيرين في همم
المجتمع الاحسائي لان خلاص في القطيف
الحركيين شغلهم على الشيرازيه